- Cette gare a un lourd passi, ,
qu'ont transité une partie des
13 000 Juifs déportés en 1942
vers les camps d'extermination
mondiale. 80 ans après la rafle
du Vél d'Hiv, la France rend
dimanche hommage aux victimes
dans l'ancienne gare.
le combat contre l'antisémitisme
n'est pan'est pan'est pas termi.
EMMANUEL MACRON,
président de la France
- Nous devons en faire
le constat lucide. Cet
plus brûlant, rampant,
qu'il ne l'était en 1995,
dans not
dans tant d'endroits du monde.
- En 1942, des policiers
et des gendarmes français
arrestatifs.
Le président Jacques Chirac a
la responsabilité de son pays
dans les déportations.
La première ministre de
des autorités françaises pendant
50 ans.
ELISABETH BORNE, p
ministre de la France
- Notre pays a attendu 1995
et les mots du président Jacques
s, pour reconnaitre
sa responsabilité.à
Drancy.
- À Montréal, cet anniversaire
souvenirs à Georgette Brinberg..
Cette survivante avait 3 ans au
GEORGETTE BRINBERGte
de la rafle de Vél d'Hiv
je me rappelle réellement,
c'est de tenir la main de
ma mère et de crier parce que
- Sa mère a été transportée à
Auschwitlle est morte.
Avec sa soeur, Georgette
Brinberg a réussi à éviter
enfuies et une famille fançaise
les ont ndant 4 ans.
- Parce que il faut que
la jeunesse sache, pour que
Ça peut se reproduire,
mais espérons que ça ne se
tte Brinberg est arrivée
au Canada, en 1955. Depuis,
elle se donne la mission
les jeunes en faisant des
dans les écoles.
Ici Charlotte Dumoulin,
Radio-Canada, Mon